some of the newest features that you've
added to the camera are the new mount
and playback feature can you tell us
more about those two features and are
there going to be any new features added
before the digital bollocks hits
consumers there are still a few hidden
features for the digital bollocks that
will be releasing as they become
available so there are still some things
that will be new even after the camera
comes out there will be firmware updates
that unlock things that we haven't told
people about
we are keeping under our hats for now
too because you know competition
machines
um and so but we are hopefully very
close to a finished camera design most
of the electronics the design is done
there is now just a firmware to get past
writing pen implementing we have made a
couple small changes to the body even
recently I think last week we added a
pin for putting measuring tape on so
that you could measure represents focus
your focus on a measuring tape and
things like that but those are mostly
very small almost cosmetic changes yeah
I mean specifically the turret mount
that we added this because we're
building custom lenses
the Bullock's was known for back in the
day was the ability to put three small
prime lenses on front of the camera and
switch them easily by just sort of
moving the turret and that allows you to
get you know a wide range of shots while
still using primers which tend to be
higher quality lenses and so you know
that's something that people have almost
jokingly been asking us about since we
started the project but it was something
that we also had always been thinking
about and so as soon as we realize that
it was possible you know that's
something that we've been developing
really actively because one thing is you
know our our engineering team is based
in Toronto and that means that we do
have some time here to work with as joe
said other partners and the people that
were working with on the
that's a completely separate team and
they're amazing and you know the types
of discussions the in-depth discussions
we've had with them on what type of lens
is
create is pretty impressive playback was
something that is slightly more
complicated a lot of it has to do with
firmware and so it becomes more of a
question of like making sure that we
build the hardware in that we know can
support features we want to add later
that will appear through the firmware so
a lot of sort of the updates that he's
mentioning that haven't been announced
have to do with sort of components that
will already be shipped inside the
camera but may not be able to be
activated until we figure out how to
program at it
but playback you know was a feature that
was wanted from day one you know it's in
trying to recreate the 16-millimeter
film experience obviously you don't
really have playback on a film set but
this is a feature that with digital has
become you know universally accepted and
at this point it's probably required and
while most people are using you know
laptops on set and have this digital
workflow whether they're dumping footage
and can watch it on the computer you
know in part of wanting to keep this as
an all-in-one package that doesn't
require you to have other parts you know
playback was
we just wanted to figure out the best
way to do it before we announce that
once the camera is finally available to
the consumer if someone needs to get it
serviced for whatever reason where will
they take it well we've got one year
warranty on the camera
so they're camera companies
we've talked to I mean will be
responsible you know for fulfilling any
warranty issues we've had some really
good discussions with people who are
professionals at this kind of thing and
potentially being our go-to service
people which would be great nothing is
decided yet but even if we don't go with
someone else
you know we shipping it back to Canada
and having the people who actually made
the camera
if there is any kind of a
we're going to be establishing a
manufacturing facility and Canada that
will actually be putting the cameras
together and testing them before they go
out and that'll also be a service
facility for anything that is broken or
damaged during inter pair there we're
talking to a company right now that
works with major distribution channels
that you've heard of major websites
basically that you've heard of and is a
supplier for them this distributor also
happens to have a large repair facility
themselves so if we choose to partner
with them they may do solve the more
mechanical repairs and the ones they
can't do that it'll more electronic than
Mason still to Canada so it's a little
bit up in the air right now but because
we are starting with a very small number
of cameras only 100 and then the next
batch again will be a relatively small
number of cameras will hopefully be able
to grow into
the fit these responsibilities and as
they come we also understand that you
know it we have international interest
products so we also want people you know
if they're la-based it may be a problem
for them to have to ship something out
to Canada so as many options as we have
to get people what they need is is what
we're going to do we
you